hallo herzlich willkommen in meiner dort
mit heute gibt es bei mir kein rezept
videos sondern ein video über
verbraucherbildung ich hatte ja euch
bereits angekündigt dass ich jetzt eben
mehrere themen ansprechen möchte die ich
eben wichtig finde und habe ich auch da
um eure meinung gebeten
und ich möchte heute mit dem thema
anfangen was eigentlich gar nichts mit
ernährung zu tun hat sondern ein anderes
thema was für mich aber auch genau so
wichtig ist
und zwar geht es heute um textilien ich
habe euch ja bereits vor silvester mal
auf instagram ein foto gepostet
ihr findet mich übrigens dort auch unter
dem namen cities torten welt und da habe
ich vor silvester eben mal die kleider
von meiner tochter samira aussortiert
die kleinen kinder die wachsende immer
so schnell raus und da muss man dann
immer mal wieder schauen welche kleider
eben noch passen was aus dem schrank
raus muss und damit man eben wieder
platz für neues hat und so habe ich eben
ihre kleider aus dem ist und alles was
zu klein war habe ich dann eben alles
mal aus dem schrank rausgeschmissen und
da hat sich wirklich einiges angesammelt
gerade im winter ist es ja normal weil
man da auch viel kleid und trägt und
viele schichten und so entstanden
riesengroßer kleider berg unter meinem
bild habe ich dann viel feedback
bekommen was ich jetzt damit anstellen
könnte ich denk mal so zu 80 prozent kam
dann immer die aussage ich soll die
kleiderspenden und es ist auch so der
grund wieso ich mich jetzt für dieses
video entschieden habe weil ich heute
einfach mal zeigen möchte was man eben
mit alten textilien machen kann und mit
seinen gebrauchten textilien und dazu
nehme ich euch jetzt mal nach draußen
und zeigt euch da mal was ich stets hier
vor einem altkleidercontainer ihr kennt
die jahrtausend fach die gibt es in
jeder ortschaft hier sieht man auch ganz
groß dieses logo vom deutschen roten
kreuz
und es ist wirklich so dass ein
bruchteil dieser kleidung die ihr
spendet als er möchte die etwas gutes
tun das suggeriert ja auch dieses logo
deutsches rotes kreuz
man hat so dieses hilfe bedürfnis möchte
etwas gutes tun und ein bruchteil von
dieser kleidung kommt wirklich auch
bedürftigen hier bei uns zugute
das heißt die werden eben gesammelt und
an einer stelle an bedürftige menschen
ausgegeben
ein teil dieser container wird durch
subunternehmen
freud so wie jetzt die hier die bei uns
stehen aber es ist einfach so dass hier
second and leben die kleider nehmen und
bereiten diese auf und ihr bekommt die
dann in second hand läden zu kaufen
aber der größte teil dieser kleidung
dieser altkleider kommt wirklich nach
afrika also in die dritte welt länder
aber das wird dort nicht gespendet so
wie er es möchte also es kommt nicht den
leuten zugute sondern schadet den leuten
dort er und zwar ist es nämlich so dass
die menschen dort die gewerblich sind
eben die kleider auf kaufen ganz billig
so richtig günstigen preisen aus
deutschland die kleider werden dort gar
nicht mal aufbereitet oder so sondern
werden ganz billig verkauft die
textilhersteller sind ausgestorben weil
dort keiner so billig produzieren kann
wie eben diese kleidung dort angeboten
wird
das problem dabei ist dass sie kleidung
wirklich immer noch zu teuer ist für die
ärmsten der armen als die können sich
dann nicht mal meine rose leisten
es macht hat die wirtschaft kaputt die
textilhersteller sind kaputt und auf
jeden fall macht dann auch die kultur
kaputt denn dort gibt es gar keine
kleider kultur mehr
die tragen ihr alle da die sachen von
uns also die westlichen kleider und es
gibt auch keine traditionellen gewänder
mehr keine trachten gar nichts mehr
und das ist eben das große problem was
es mit diesen altkleider containern zu
tun hat das positive daran ist dass die
textile kette natürlich aufrecht
erhalten wird also die kleider werden
nicht irgendwie auch müll geschmissen
und verrotten dort jahrelang sie werden
benutzt und gehen weiter ich finde
einfach dass das problem ist wir denken
wir spenden die kleidung also wir
stellen uns hin und möchten etwas gutes
tun und dabei wird es einfach gewerblich
genutzt und ich finde das ist der größte
skandal daran und ich habe es jetzt nur
kurz mal so zusammengefasst das problem
mit den altkleidern ihr könnt euch dazu
einen ganz interessanten beitrag
anschauen eine dokumentation die
verlinkte ich euch hier unten in meiner
infobox dasteht info da müsst ihr darauf
klicken auf mehr anzeigen und da habe
ich verschiedene links zusammengestellt
ich finde das sollte sich wirklich jeder
mal anschauen ich denke den ein oder
anderen wird es auch wachrütteln
auch wir haben als kind weil es eben den
container hier bei uns an der straße
gibt immer die kleidung gespendet und
dachten es kommt eben den menschen
zugute aber leider ist es wirklich nicht
der fall
natürlich gibt es auch organisationen wo
man direkt spenden kann ich habe auch
einen teil
meiner kleidung dann gespendet und zwar
war die freundin meiner schwester da da
war er damals diese katastrophe auf den
philippinen und da hat ihre familie eben
auch alles verloren
da habe ich dann gewusst ich kann es ihr
mit geben und die bringt es direkt dahin
es gibt auch andere organisationen die
das direkt machen aber das solltet ihr
euch wirklich sehr gut informieren und
euch eben erkundigen was direkt
gespendet wird oder was eben wie hier
gewerblich genutzt wird
ihr kennt wahrscheinlich auch diese
tonnen und säcke die ab und zu mal vor
die haustür gestellt werden
da steht ja auch immer ganz groß drauf
dass man helfen möchte und von spenden
spenden vor allen dingen schuhe sind da
immer ganz belebt und dann müsste man
schauen da steht ganz klein gedruckt
drauf für gewerbliche zwecke
ich finde es nicht schlimm wenn menschen
das machen aber ich finde es schlimm
dass es nicht drauf schreiben und ich
denke dass ich eben dieses große problem
was es da gibt dass man das eben nicht
drauf schreibt was drin steckt so wie
eben bei den lebensmitteln was wir bald
aufklären werden
und ich finde da müsst ihr euch wirklich
gut informieren und solltet euch damit
gut auskennen
jetzt habe ich euch ja das problem mit
den altkleidern geschildert wo jetzt
fragt ihr euch bestimmt was ihr eben tun
könnt und ich habe einen
lösungsvorschlag für euch da hat mich
eine zuschauerin darauf hingewiesen und
zwar kauf ich jetzt meine kleidung bei
qimonda als dieser wieder auf die welt
kam wollte ich immer die ganze kleidung
neu kaufen und da war mein mann schon
damals so und hat gesagt kommissar
league auf die kleidung doch im
second-hand-laden aber das wollte ich
eben einfach nicht also es war irgendwie
das war mir einfach unangenehm ich
wollte wenn ich jetzt ein kind bekommen
wollte ich eben alles neu haben
mittlerweile denke ich da ganz anders
drüber und zwar ist es einfach so dass
viele schadstoffe in textilien stecken
und wenn ihr wüsstet was da alles drin
steckt in dieser kleidung dann würdet
ihr da bestimmt eure kinder nicht rein
stecken
ich habe jetzt eben die lösung mit
kieran doe gefunden da ist es so dass es
markenkleidung ist die durch eine
zweifache qualitätskontrolle geht bei
condor geht's nämlich kleidung für
kleinkinder und eben größere kinder da
könnt ihr euch wie in einem ganz
normalen job die kleider auszuruhen und
zu euch nach hause kommen lassen
davis dir einfach dass die qualität
stimmt es sind keine schadstoffe
enthalten weil die kleider getragen sind
und weil sie eben
waschen sind und für jeden einkauf dir
dort tätig spende scirocco einen
gewissen beitrag an soziale
einrichtungen wie beispielsweise die
arche region durch es so dass ihr da
jetzt nicht nur markenkleidung kaufen
könnt ihr könnt auch markenkleidung
verkaufen und das ist auch der grund
meines videos so habe ich nämlich jetzt
mit samir us markenkleidung auch gemacht
ich habe die kleidung die eben noch gut
aussieht die markenkleidung habe ich
aussortiert und in eine tüte gesteckt
die man sich kostenlos anfordern kann
da könnt ihr alle markenkleidung
reinstecken die eben gerne verkaufen
würde und kondomen acht da ebene
zweifach qualitätskontrolle
da wird die qualität überprüft da werden
die kleider auch gewaschen und
fotografiert und werden dann eben online
in dieses in diesem qimonda shop
gesteckt und die kleidung die nicht
verkauft werden kann weil sie den
anforderungen nicht entspricht die wird
dann eben gespendet da müsst ihr auf
jeden fall die checkliste beachten die
gibt es da auch online das verlinkte ich
euch unten in meiner infobox da dürfte
jetzt natürlich keine großen beträge
erwarten denn das ganze muss ja auch
wirtschaftlich bleiben qimonda hat einen
sehr großen aufwand dann auch mit eurer
kleidung er bekommt ja zuerst einmal
diese kostenlose tüte dürfte es
einschicken
dann wird es zweimal kontrolliert wird
gewaschen es wird aufbereitet
die kleidung mit fotografiert und
eingestellt sie wird gelagert und das
ganze bleibt dann eben in seinem
kreislauf und da dürfte jetzt keine
großen beträge erwarten also wenn ihr
jetzt mal eine jack wolfskin jacke für
50 euro gekauft habt dürft jetzt nicht
erwarten dass ihr da noch 20 euro dafür
bekommt aber das soll ja auch gar nicht
sinn und zweck davon sein dass man star
das große geld damit macht das sind
davon ist ja dass die kleidung eben in
der textilen kette aufrechterhalten
bleibt und dass er eben einfach etwas
gutes tut ihr bekommt ein kleinen
beitrag zurück in euren geldbeutel könnt
damit nochmal neue kleidung bzw
gebrauchte kleidung bei kunde kaufen und
das ganze bleibt eben in einem kreislauf
manche unterstützt soziale projekte und
ich finde die sache einfach richtig
super und ich habe jetzt beispielsweise
die samira komplett mit ihrem
wintersachen ausgestattet mit dieser
jack wolfskin jacke
ich habe ihr die hose dazu gekauft und
wenn dieser jetzt da bald auch wieder
raus wächst wenn der winter vorbei ist
kann ich die kleidung einfach wieder ein
kino zurück verkaufen bekommen da eben
wieder einen kleinen beitrag dafür
und so kommt es kommt eben immer wieder
auch im laufenden halten
natürlich musste auch gewährleistet sein
dass die marken zeitung dann immer noch
den qualitätsanforderungen entspricht
aber schickt einfach ein
denn wenn sie eben nicht verkauft werden
kann wird sie gespendet und man tut
wirklich gutes natürlich sagen jetzt
bestimmt manche sally es gibt doch auch
flohmärkte auf denen man meine kleidung
verkaufen kann
da habt ihr recht das habe ich auch
schon gemacht ich stand nämlich genau
ein einziges mal auf dem flohmarkt und
hab mich da als verkäuferin versucht was
natürlich leider etwas gescheitert ist
weil ich keine gute flohmarkt
verkäuferin bindet aber da ist einfach
so dass ihr daran entstand mieten müsst
ihr steht auf dem ganzen tag das ist
wetterabhängig das heißt entweder weg
wird oder es scheint die sonne
ihr müsst damit leuten verhandeln und im
endeffekt bekommt ihr da vielleicht ein
paar euro raus aber habt eben auch einen
ganzen tag investiert
für uns war es mal eine schöne erfahrung
ich stand mit meinem mann er hat über
mich gelacht weil er besser verkäufer in
stein schwabe und für mich ist es leider
nix und deswegen kaufe und verkaufe ich
meine kleidung lieber über kleve und ihr
kennt mich ja ich bin ja ein sympathie
mensch bei mir spielt sympathie immer
eine ganz große rolle
deswegen habe ich auch bei kunde
angerufen habe mir dieses
geschäftskonzept daneben auch richtig
angeschaut und möchte da hat dem nichts
dann auch mal hinfahren und das
unternehmen besuchen
mir ist es nämlich ganz wichtig dass das
unternehmen auch seriös ist und eben
dass da einfach die beziehung stimmt ich
werde da auf jeden fall auch mal
vorbeischauen wollte ich sowieso schon
immer und ich denke das kann ich jetzt
so ganz gut verbinden
da würde ich auch mal gerne die kinder
sehen das sag ich mal was mit denen ich
finde es einfach schön zu sehen wenn
eure hilfe da ankommt wo sie eben auch
gebraucht wird
opa willi
mit thomas senior
weil die musik bleibt schießen
ich hoffe ich konnte euch in diesem
kurzen video einfach mal einen einblick
in diese textil welt geben
natürlich konnte ich jetzt nicht alle
stationen und ansprechen dass ich auch
wirklich unmöglich das in einem video zu
machen
deswegen lege ich das wirklich ans herz
euch die dokumentationen auch mal
anzuschauen
die ich euch hier unten in der infobox
eben auch verlinke da wo info steht
bietet draufklicken das in alle links
noch mal zu finden und ich denke dass
ich für euch auch sehr wichtig ich finde
die lösung mit kundus sehr gut denn die
runde ist nachhaltig ich tue etwas für
mich ich tue das für mein kind ich tu
was für meinen geldbeutel und für die
umwelt
und ich denke da hat wirklich jeder was
davon und das solltet ihr euch auf jeden
fall mal anschauen und nächste woche
werde ich dann wieder auf das thema
ernährung kommen und werde da das
lebensmittelkennzeichnung gesetz man
unter die lupe nehmen
da werden wir verbrauchen nämlich
richtig an der nase herumgeführt
da zeige ich euch mal wie so eine
rindswurst zu 100 prozent aus
rindfleisch besteht sie aber in einem
schweine darm steckt oder weshalb sich
einige flügel wurst geflügel wurst
nennen darf obwohl da fast 90% schwein
drin steckt oder aber auch weshalb
werden apfelsaft trinken der vorher mit
gelatine behandelt wurde mit noch ganz
besonders wichtig eigentlich sogar
wichtiger als in meine bank oder koch
videos dass ihr dieses video wenn es
euch gefallen hat auch teilt damit
wirklich so viele menschen wie möglich
eben auch mal aufgeklärt werden
und da eben mit unterstützen können denn
je mehr leute wir sind umso mehr können
wir auch erreichen
ich hoffe dass euch dieses video
gefallen hat ich würde mich natürlich
über eine bewertung freuen auch über
einen kommentar halt ihr noch weitere
fragen habt könnt ihr gerne unten in der
kommentarbox stellen
ich werde dann versuchen sie zu
beantworten da können wir gern noch
etwas weiter diskutieren
und falls es noch andere video ideen
habt lasst mich auch ganz gerne wissen
ich freue mich schon auf euer feedback
und wünsche euch noch einen ganz schönen
tag bis bald
jetzt aber genug zu mir hinkommt
verteidigung ist habe ich versprochen
die letzten mal
tipp aus frisst mich doch aufschlag
jedoch ein ich stehe total
ich kann kein deutsch mehr
ich stehe zu 100 prozent hinter dem
konzept von kino.to ist nachhaltig und
kieran doe ist sinnvoll jetzt aber genug
von mir jetzt so schön gesagt
aber wo ich stehe und da freue ich mich
schon ich finde es einfach schön wenn
man sehen kann ok es kommt wirklich da
an wo man es eben da haben auch möchte
ich möchte danke
schreiber war ständig lustig über mich
richtig auf ja